[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the judge has to determine if they can
set aside anything they've heard and
whether or not they've made up their
mind about innocence versus guilt jury
selection begins in the pike county
massacre for one of the four charged in
the case defendant george wagner iv plus
gabby petito's parents seeking 50
million dollars in damages as part of a
new lawsuit alleging moab utah police
officials were negligent leading to the
22-year-old's death and three men are
sentenced in federal court after being
convicted of both state and federal
charges in the death of a mod arbory and
later if you go into a room full of
republicans and ask who wants safe
schools everybody raises their hands go
in a room full of democrats and ask that
same question everyone raises their
hands long crime sat down with the
father of a parkland school shooting
victim as the penalty phase trial takes
a week-long break from proceedings long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long prime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
jury selection is underway in pike
county ohio for one of the four family
members accused in the pike county
massacre eight members of the rhoden and
gilley families were shot to death in
april of 2016. now george wagner iv
faces trial long crimes angenette levy
tells us why picking a jury could be a
challenge
pike county is a small community it's
the type of place where a lot of people
know each other and that has come up a
lot during the first day of jury
selection in the trial of george wagner
iv most jurors in the venue potential
jurors who are 18 and over have heard of
the wagner family they've heard of the
rhoden
family they know what happens alan
turkheimer is a jury consultant advising
clients on picking jurors he says simply
knowing about the case doesn't mean a
person can't serve as a juror the key
question is and judges have a lot of
discretion here the judge has to
determine if they can set aside anything
they've heard and whether or not they've
made up their mind about innocence
versus guilt finding 12 impartial jurors
in pike county could be a challenge
because of the small jury pool the
county has fewer than 28 thousand
residents one thousand prospective
jurors filled out this 21-page
questionnaire answering questions about
where they get their news their feelings
on the death penalty and whether they
use social media wagner's attorneys had
us to move the trial but judge randy
dearing said they would try to seat a
jury in pike county before considering a
change of venue news of the murders of
eight members of the rhoden and gilley
families in april of 2016 garnered
national and international attention so
there's no question people know about
the case the arrests of four members of
the wagner family two and a half years
later also made headlines
and just to give you a sense of what's
going on in the courtroom one of the
prospective jurors said that she works
at a local police department and her
father is an emt who actually responded
to one of the rodent crime scenes the
morning of the murders and her mother
worked with one of the victims for a
short time
in pike county ohio i'm angenette levy
for law and crime daily
all right let's break this down joining
me today are long crime legal analysts
julie rendellman and civil rights
attorney joe richardson it's good to see
you both joe i'll start with you
chances the judge actually decides to
change venue here after everything is
said and done
it would probably be slim is the short
the issue is this small county people
are very likely to know about the
incident and sometimes each other or
someone connected to it but ohio is
notoriously uh slim on uh letting juries
be uh places be uh cases be brought into
other venues and in any event this judge
wants to try to get a jury seated in
this county first and then cross the
bridge if he comes to it uh as to them
not being able to get an objective jury
seated i'm gonna be easier said than
done julie we have to make an
interesting point here that even though
this is a death penalty case
wagner may never be executed because of
this deal that was made by his brother
jake can you walk us through it
sure so jake wagner pled guilty
and made
entered into a cooperation agreement
with the prosecutor basically giving him
a life sentence as long as he testified
truthfully against his brother one of
the caveats is that he doesn't want his
brother to get the death penalty and the
prosecutor's position is we'll do that
but you still have to testify they are
not taking it off the table until and
unless jake wagner testifies and
testifies truthfully with regards to
what his brother did julie real quick
have you ever seen a deal like that
um it's interesting because you know in
new york we don't have the death penalty
um and so i'm not surprised especially
keeping in mind that can you imagine a
brother testifying against his own
brother knowing that he could be the
reason that he's put to death so it
makes sense in a case like this that
they would ask for
um you know some type of understanding
if he's going to testify against his own
sibling it's a unique deal but also a
very unique set of circumstances to say
the least also out in ohio a suspect
wanted for the shooting deaths of four
people is katri is captured hundreds of
miles away after a two-day manhunt
authorities say 39-year-old steven
marlow was taken into custody in kansas
days after the murders of husband and
wife clyde and eva knox and mother and
daughter sarah and kayla anderson in the
dayton ohio area the knox couple were
killed in their home and the
andersons were killed in a separate
house authorities say the killings
happened in the same neighborhood near a
home owned by the suspect's parents now
police have not said what they believe
is a motive in the murders but they are
aware of a video that marlow released on
tick tock sometime after the shooting in
which he claimed he was a victim of mind
control and that he quote cannot sit by
and be a victim any longer our thoughts
are not private i will be launching the
first
attack against mind control in human
history marlow will be extradited to
ohio to face charges
and still ahead on long crime daily i
sat down with the father of parkland
school shooting victim gina montalto to
talk about the steps that he's taken for
change since the shooting but first the
parents of gabby petito announced plans
of another lawsuit in connection to the
death of their daughter
[Music]
welcome back everybody a renewed push
for solving the 1996 death of
six-year-old jonbenet ramsey this as her
father remembers the little girl on what
would have been her 32nd birthday
jonbenet's story captured the attention
of millions when she went missing and
was ultimately found dead in the
family's basement around christmas in
1996. it was wildly believed that either
her mother her father or brother killed
her but investigators have never
determined who strangled her to death
the daughter of a detective who first
proposed the intruder theory that would
exonerate the ramsey family along with a
team of 12 volunteer amateur
investigators are now joining the little
girl's father john in a new push for dna
testing on her fingernail samples long
johns and underwear john proposed
updated technology and genealogical
tools could be used to identify the
beauty queen's killer the ramsey family
sent a request to colorado's governor to
hand over the investigation to a private
company but he has not made a ruling yet
regarding the case
gabby petito's family announces they
plan to file a wrongful death lawsuit
against police in moab utah alleging
negligence that led to her death last
year joseph and tara petito and nicole
and jim schmidt are seeking 50 million
dollars in damages against the moab
police department including three of its
officers and 10 other unnamed defendants
the family claimed negligent failure in
the investigation into the alleged
basalt between potato and her fiance
brian laundry while the two were on a
cross-country road trip prior to her
murder petito was killed in september
last year her body found a week after
she was reported missing near a remote
campground in grand teton national
forest laundry was also found dead weeks
later after he returned home to florida
without her a notebook found near his
remains included a confession to killing
his fiancee in august the couple
recorded on body cameras speaking to
moab officers after having a verbal and
physical fight petito's family say those
officers failed in their duty to protect
their daughter
i again don't want to get into specifics
of of what happened that day there's a
lot of information that has been made
available but there's much information
that is not yet available publicly
um but i will say that we do agree with
the findings of the investigative report
that the
officers failed to
recognize the serious danger that she
was in and failed to investigate fully
and properly
they
did not have the training that they
needed to recognize the clear signs that
were evident that morning
that gabby was a victim and that she was
in serious need of immediate help
it was also clear from the officers
themselves and the findings of the
report that they
did not understand
the law
and did not apply the law properly in
gabby's situation
julie clearly this is a very big
development but do you think that this
is a strong case i mean the question is
if the officers acted differently would
gabby be alive
and that's an impossible question to
answer in a sense first of all hindsight
2020 do i think that they acted
negligently when it came to what
happened absolutely i mean this is a
domestic violence case had they made an
arrest they would have arrested one or
both of them that would have guaranteed
an order protection put in place and
would have given off what we call a
cooling off period allowing them to
separate not just for the night but
perhaps longer um and so they didn't do
that they didn't investigate and and
that's a real problem the problem for
the family of of gabriel potito is was
it foreseeable at the end of the day
that a death would have occurred and
that i'm not so sure of and i think the
other issue that's going to come up is
whether or not there's any immunity for
the officers in utah regarding this type
of civil litigation i see this joe as
having big implications for other police
departments so it makes me wonder if you
were the moab police would you fight
this or do you settle it out of court
i might fight it in the initial moment
if i thought that i could get rid of it
in an early dispositive motion or a
later dispositive motion based on
immunities or issues of law then maybe i
fight it and then if i lose at that
point then i settle it otherwise here
though it's going to draw a lot of
attention maybe more than they want
frankly for the family this is much
closer than the case in florida which
was absolutely going nowhere and they
may decide because they did make an
error causation is a separate thing like
julie says but maybe they decide to
settle and cut their losses and joe real
quick other police departments i think
are going to be looking at this case
oh yeah no doubt about it they're going
to look and see how much liability they
potentially have if they get a call
wrong even if the causation is separate
utah they might be a little bit better
off because it's cause in fact it has to
be the cause in other states where
negligence can be a-caused then they may
have a problem yeah this is a lawsuit
that i think we're going to follow
carefully and see which way it
ultimately develops
coming up on long crime daily three men
convicted in the murder of unarmed black
man ahmad arbury are sentenced in
federal court plus a father of one of
the victims of the parkland school
shooting sits down with law and crime
amid a break in the gunman's penalty
phase trial
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back the three men convicted
in the 2020 shooting death of ahmad
arbory are sentenced in federal court
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael and their neighbor william
roddy bryan were previously convicted in
state court and sentenced to life in
prison for the murder of a mod arbory
this after they armed themselves to
chase down the unarmed black man
assuming he was a burglar a federal jury
in february found mcmichaels and brian
killed arbory because of his race they
were also found guilty of federal
kidnapping charges attorneys assigned to
the defendants previously requested
their clients be sentenced to federal
prison for their own safety all three
men are already serving life sentences
for their convictions in state court on
monday travis and gregory were both
given second life sentences plus ten and
seven years respectively for their
federal hate crimes convictions and
brian was sentenced to 35 years late
monday afternoon
so joe i guess the question is what is
the difference between being locked up
in federal prison versus state prison
namely it tends to be safer you're more
likely to deal with white-collar
criminals folks that are less violent
etc so you add that along with the
notion that in georgia things would be
very hot as it were
with them being in state prison and they
would fear for their safety perhaps if
they're out of state somewhere else that
there'd be a little less uh you know
relative sensitivity to the issue so
between that and then being less safe uh
the prisons being considered more safe
on the federal side they would prefer to
be on the federal side as opposed to the
state where your criminals are a lot
more violent julie somebody could look
at this and say they were already locked
away from in life in prison so what do
these sentences mean
considering they already had life in
prison on the state charges
you're right not in a sense not much
because they're already
at least with regards to travis
mcmichael and his father they're already
serving life sentences in state court so
they're never getting out no matter what
whereas with uh roddy roddy brian it's a
little different uh because he his
sentence was um there was a potential
for parole in his state case um the one
thing it does though is keep in mind
they're going to appeal and if they are
not successful with their state appeal
keep in mind they still have to appeal
the federal case so it's going to be
tough to get two bites of the apple in
terms of trying to get um their cases
disposed of in a way that's positive for
them so at least these guilty these
sentences make that much more difficult
for for each of the defendants julie
were you surprised 35 years for brian
i i wasn't i think it was important for
the judge to distinguish the behavior
between each of the three men and and
show the sentences that were appropriate
for those that pulled the trigger versus
that individual that participated but
potentially had less culpability uh than
the two major players yeah it's
definitely a major development in a
story that first started with a cell
phone video and has worked its way
through state court and now federal
court and it's just incredible to see
how it started and where it ultimately
ended up
new mexico investigators say a fourth
murder of a muslim man may be connected
to three other similar killings
officials in albuquerque announced their
press conference over the weekend that
they have reason to believe that the
killing of a man last week is related to
killings of other muslim men in the area
two members of the same mosque were
murdered in the last two weeks and
investigators already determined their
killings were connected detectives are
trying to determine if their deaths are
related to another murder in november of
last year and the fourth killing last
week police say the victims were all
ambushed with no warning and fired upon
and killed there is a fifteen thousand
dollar reward for information that helps
lead to an arrest the fbi is now
assisting in the investigation in
addition to local officials at a press
conference albuquerque police department
chief harold medina said they are using
every possible resource to bring the
killer to justice
i want to send the same message to the
entire community
they're putting every possible resource
into these investigations
our top priority is keeping the
community safe
and asking the muslim community
especially to be vigilant to watch out
for one another if you see something say
something report it to police we've also
increased the priority of any of our
calls involving uh the muslim community
which may be a disturbance or any type
of incident which could lead uh to
further injury of anybody from that
community you know historically if we
look at these types of incidents across
the country it's that community tip that
helps solve
these cases and bring
justice to the families that are
impacted in the city of albuquerque our
strength is our diversity we're an
extremely diverse community we're
melting part of different cultures
and i'm asking all of albuquerque to
stand strong with with our muslim
community evil will not prevail
when we come back the parkland school
shooting penalty phase trial takes a
week-long break and we sit down with one
victim's father who created an
organization for change in his
daughter's name
[Music]
welcome back everybody i had the
incredible opportunity to sit down with
the father of one of the victims of the
parkland school shooting this is the
penalty phase trial for the gunman takes
a break a break this week
fourteen-year-old gina montalto was one
of the 17 students and staff members who
was killed on valentine's day in 2018 at
marjory stoneman douglas high school her
father tony started an organization in
her name after the mass shooting to help
students with the cost of post-secondary
education and make charitable donations
to causes his daughter supported tony
testified at the penalty phase trial
wearing the suit that he wore to the
last father-daughter dance he attended
with gina as i sat down with him he told
me what he what needs to happen to make
schools safer
i think that
[Music]
but the idea of doing nothing is
unacceptable the idea of
you know
well it's not going to be perfect so we
won't do anything
we have to stop that thing we have to
come together as an american family
if you go into a room full of
republicans and ask who wants safe
schools everybody raises their hands go
in a room full of democrats and ask that
same question everyone raises their
hands we have to start looking at what
unites us here
you know we are the united states of
america
and we have to stop uh bickering with
the far left and the far right and start
coming together as an american family to
make our students and teachers safer at
school
so joe when i spoke to tony he walked me
through their efforts for the last four
years to make changes on the legislative
front and it was amazing to hear
everything that they've been doing but
as i was listening and i wanted to talk
to you about it
do you think that we can be in a
position to ensure that there's not
another parkland or sandy hook or uvalde
in the future
we couldn't totally insure it in any
event can we make it less likely so that
question becomes in turn
what about the conditions that created
this instance are they more likely to
continue to occur there's a mental
health element and people recognize that
and that's out there and maybe in most
in recent legislation that's been
addressed somewhat there's a idea of
school safety evaluated there's a
argument that some other things could
have been done in that regard by the
police who did nothing
but at the end of the day it's about the
culture of violence and the ease of
purchase of firearms you still have to
deal with that one way or the other and
without dealing with that i think that
that's the single most important element
that's going to help along with the
others to hopefully get to a place to
make this less likely and what was
interesting about speaking with tony is
he focused so much attention not even on
the gun control debate but more so
finding the warning signs which it
seemed that both sides could agree on
that that was a common factor in all of
these shootings now julie just going
back to the trial for a second
there is this two-week delay and i'm
curious this two-week delay before the
defense begins is that an advantage to
them
let me be clear when i say whether they
put it over for two weeks two months two
years 20 years the jury
has been impacted permanently for what
they've heard already from the victims
and the family members of the
individuals that passed away and were
injured so i don't think it really at
the end of the day matters does it give
them a little more time to cross their
t's and dot their eyes for things
perhaps they missed uh when they were
when the prosecution was going through
the case of course but do i think it's
going to matter in any way shape or form
to this jury when they're listening uh
to the mitigation absolutely absolutely
not
it is an uphill battle for this defense
to try to save the life of their client
after everything this jury has seen
joe julie thank you so much really
appreciate it and everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you